what a difference a year makes one year
ago today governor sissel act
passionately pleaded to all nevadans to
stay home ahead of shutting down
all gaming and non-essential businesses
in our state
thank you for joining us at 6 p.m i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez so
fast forward to today
the governor announcing all nevadans
over 16 will be eligible for a vaccine
by april 5th
now this as vaccines show promising
results and are giving nevadans more
hope
now as nevada continues to recover we
are tracking our recovery
with team coverage here at 6. joe
moeller has a look back at how far we've
come
since the pandemic shutdown while sally
jaramillo has a look at how the
community is moving forward
but we begin tonight with orco mana with
the latest details on the governor's
vaccination plan
or go he said he was going to deliver
his
new news today and that was big news
that beginning on april 5th
all nevadans aged 16 and older will be
eligible to get the covet 19 vaccine
and that's in just two and a half weeks
more immediately
starting on march 22nd nevadans age 16
and older who have underlying health
conditions
will be able to get the vaccine now
those appointments will be available
through the retail pharmacy program
this expanded eligibility comes as
nevada's overall allocation of the covet
19 vaccine
has been increasing we're approaching 1
million doses given in our state
and the governor says nevada is now
getting nearly 65
000 doses a week much higher than the 45
thousand we were getting just a few
weeks
ago and with all nevadans aged 16 and
older able to sign up for a vaccine
appointment in april
officials are hopeful for the future
nevada will be the safest place to have
a convention
or come and visit will be safe for the
tourists
and business travelers will be safe for
employees
and will be safe for their families we
are
intent on making nevada the safest
healthiest place to come
and vacation or have your next
convention now while governor sysolak
says things look
promising he wants to make it clear that
the actual availability of vaccine
appointments
will still be dependent on how many
doses nevada gets from the federal
government
so he is encouraging patients during
this process
state health officials say they're
expecting more shipments of the johnson
and johnson vaccine to come
toward the end of march the beginning of
april and that'll help distribution
efforts and once again
they're reiterating when you become
eligible you should get vaccinated
live in the newsroom tonight orca mana 8
news now